let's see Sammy get this thing out of
here
get it out of here actually I should
just push you to the side so I could be
aware of it I have to do that next time
Wow keep making mouse lips it's gonna
come back to bite you it's gonna come
back to bite you geez geez geez geez
let's see ecigs I'm on the Queen clock
is ticking tick tick tick tick tick
queen is ready to take a beating
she's ready to take a beating not so
fast okay but there's the Queen's gonna
have to move again is what I'm getting
at she's gonna have to move again she
does not like being on that open file
the Queen does not belong there it's the
rooks territory at least in this
position I don't want to trade I don't
want to trade like that let's go here no
no what night-night here I'd just give a
check on B for time issue let's get to
the centre tricks tricks on c2 tricks on
c2 pins pins and tricks get this pawn
queen d2 is needed Queen B to get this
pawn right here Queen to d2 is a good
move forks for X force move what are you
doing okay let's take a rookie take a
pond just I'm gonna take here even
though it's losing a rope and this I
just I don't want my time to burn it all
huh I just got my queen I didn't need to
do that one it's a good thing I have a
lot of time I could be tricky check back
to tournament oh what a way to start
just drop your queen it'll be okay just
drop your queen and everything's gonna
be okay okay d4 Knight f3 Oh
Oh tricky stuff we're not okay now put
pressure on this immediately and then
and then what if the queen bee five I'm
on the night I'm on the tricky night
okay there goes my light square bishop I
got D five though if the Queen I'm on c2
this is winning I got the rookie the
rook is dead looking for the King next
there might be pins what am I missing
anything
if King went to the diagonal I had
Bishop to c5 instead let's go here
there's no tricks no tricks no tricks
take this oh I could give a check right
here I should have done that now it's
lethal isn't it close to Lethal lethal
leap oh here we go oh boy
Oh trouble pins hit the pinned piece
pile up on the Queen I'm covering c7
with my night come on this is reasonable
you know it is you know it's reasonable
check leading to me just take take the
rip next either back to tournament ten
six five three ten six five three ten
six five three here we go here we go
more of this Center century oh I say
Senate central control that's what I
meant to say right there push my
opponent around push the night and then
win a night till one night one night
here come on they know they're down
material why don't they you know what if
they resigning they're trying to beat me
on time whoa wait a second wait a second
let's get out of that let's get out of
that very soon Oh scary diagonal right
here very very scary get out of there
get out of there let's do this
I don't even move my queen there that
was silly I was silly Queen 2d6 would
have been safer there is no Bishop takes
with check ik go like that I'm gonna
tuck my okay they missed that I was
gonna suck my Queen in right there on f7
and now
okay back to tournament that was a quick
one eighteen twelve I have 12 somebody
has 18 p TN p TN 2175 okay no all right
this is this is good this is good this
is like Philidor I spy ever so slight
transposition Philidor oh I'm in a trap
a killer trap ah why did I fall for that
take my bishop now good at least get
this right and get the rook and be
sneaky I'm not gonna take the pawn next
then maybe they're thinking I'm taking
the pond Oh somebody's being sneaky okay
let me do what next let's come over here
watch h3 and do what next put pressure
on this pond pressure on this pond no
actually I want to put pressure on this
no no no no I should have pressure on
that pond first okay okay okay okay okay
okay
the night has to defend let's get this
in I'm looking to trap the bishop now
uh-oh I got the piece back it's trapped
and I'm on this pond a second time or a
third time after I take here we go
crashing through crashing through a
bunch of exchanges and I got to come
back here defend my pawns here for just
a second I have a time edge okay I
fought back there I fought back there
King improvement King improvement no no
no no no get up get up get over here
pawn push let's do this take take take
take take defend okay why did I do that
I have a terrible King position now
now let's go here let's come back here
run away go here sneaky move take defend
defend come back here hit the King avoid
the crook exchanges whatever you do time
burner more time burners needed time
burners take this don't get both puns
don't get both pawns whatever you do
don't get both puns
well back to turn oh that was a
nail-biter
that was a nail-biter were three 20s
twenty twenty twenty nineteen sixteen
capper OTT was a guy that ran away with
it the one time I don't know if it was
this tournament but he had like a huge
lead a huge lead you gotta win every
game you've got to win every May every
every mean they remain what is that
every game lady for that Bishop now this
Knight is dead well it was dead earlier
just because of c6 here we go and I got
the bishop I got the bishop looking for
tricks tricky tricky tricky trick trick
trick Trick or Treat trick or treat
yes it was a trick it was a trick
everybody saab searching for bobby
fisher' didn't they that's been here you
know about trick or treat okay here we
go that was a trick I was a clearance
that was the better description more
descriptive is the word clearance right
there I was clearing the way so my queen
can see the Queen wanted to see take the
night hang on hang on hang on hang and
I'll take like this okay let's get out
of that let's get out of that let's play
here and then do what next
okay I don't even know what this is
doing stop might be for stuff eventually
right like right now and then let's not
do that
looking and get over in this direction
and then they're being sneaky back here
they're definitely being sneaky back I'm
not sure what this move is doing not
quite sure what it's doing there
Oh Oh Queen takes pawn is available when
he takes pawn not anymore
take my bishop Knight right here is
available next maybe I'm watching over
g2 oh I dropped my bishop
I dropped my bishop they missed it maybe
they're missing my queen defending this
laterally might be missing that they
might miss it they might miss it that
Bishop has to go and I'm gonna give up
this just so I could get this pawn I
have the rook maybe let's do this Oh
rook takes Bishop crap I'm in trouble I
should've did this rook takes Bishop
still or no it doesn't work it doesn't
work or it does work it does work I'd
get made it if I played my other R up
there uh how much time I have to prevent
that like it that's all I could do
that's all I could do is just burn time
push upon give a check time burner time
burners I'm looking for the time burners
42 38 thank you clock the clock is my
best friend in this tournament so far
the clock is my best friend I tell you
come on four pawns attack is that really
a thing here my opponent is having no
problems just let's go with five five is
better than four isn't it here we go
let's do it let's do this
push them around push again rip this
open here rip it open tricky stuff
coming up
killer forks killer forks but my
opponent is getting a couple pawns for
it at least definitely getting a couple
pawns for it right
it's my rook ready to be trapped soon
somehow man oh okay I could do this
get that pawn back look at my minor
pieces do something else would you what
are my minor pieces doing okay I'm going
here so my knight could move oh yes yes
yes yes yes they drop the rook back to
tournament come on just resign I mean
just resign the knight is I'm hitting f2
hitting f2 come on let's go here
okay there we go here we go no it's
looking good
it's looking good now okay let's stop
that bishop from doing anything
the knight is boxed out the knight is
out of moves the knight is officially
out of moves okay except for that one
let's go King let's go King okay now I
have an edge on time lead I'm that and
then just push push push push
give a check if they go there push oh
man it was close to stalemate I thought
back to tournament 56 56 55 it
neck-and-neck this guy again
Lord something Lord of the Rings is that
a ring right there here we go here we go
oh we have this before no no no no no no
c3 and come on now let's do this let us
do this launch that pun oh okay dark
square bishop I went through dark square
bishop are they gonna give me that no
they're not
let's come here I could block on this
square yes they're giving me their dark
square bishop that's great that is great
let's stop the night if he goes here I
want to just take it oh I didn't mean to
do that a 3 and B 4 is what I wanted and
now I can't take my rooks unprotected
okay now I want to do this and then play
here get my knight either way I'm on my
night out and see what I want my knight
on c5 quickly very very quickly I need
to block this up in my other night on f4
there we go that one's sealed get my
other night on f4 come back here and now
I read thing is gonna be nice and smooth
here right it should be nice and smooth
in theory it should be smooth should be
smooth sailing I have a grip and now
whoa it's coming under fire at this
point let's guard here my queen could do
a bit more Oh
I was nervous right there I thought
there would be a pawn push and then upon
push again
let's get over here sneaky my opponent
is definitely being sneaky right now
definitely oh there's a fork there's a
fork there's a fork on this square right
here right here
hopefully it's okay though hopefully
it's okay that's not working is it
hmm it's very nuts right there very very
nuts okay I have this defendant
I haven't defended I want to trade
Queens Queen right here I'll trade
Queens
let's go King I still have okay my rook
the rook is dead the rook is dead my
king is gonna march right in the center
my Knights getting back to this Square
and this pond could fall next I have
enough coverage for it and then get my
knight back here and then give it a
check come over here they're probably
gonna be giving me a check or thinking
about it at least give a check come back
just burn their time we're here over
here making one yeah it's back to
tournament 84-83 no 83 the 83 72 72
somebody hasn't lead this is the guy
that's in the lead this is guy that's in
the lead let's see yes here easy he
resigned Oh
82 81 82 81
oh it was a resigner okay if we end up
in a tie if we end up in a tie then what
does that mean I would win out on
tiebreaks cuz I'm I've won Oh against
him okay what is this what is this now
just pod push take that night and then
take on f4 okay push that night away
instead push that night away can I get
that in okay now I'm just up and just up
a free pond well not a free pond but
it's almost like it's free two to zero
majority very little compensation giving
me the dark square bishop looking for
something on this diagonal Knight goes
here it's pinned okay I want to chase
that night away I want to get on this
diagonal hitting the knight my bishop
here take I'm on the night I want to
break this down I have a bunch of pawns
now let's just remove any support points
my opponent might have King to f2 if
there's a check came to f2 if there's a
check and then rook to e1 okay
let's go here Queen check and then
something with no not really
that's not happening let's get just
finish my development let's do this
first and then grab on c5 grab on c5
next and then if Bishop blocks it I
could eventually gain a temple with
Knight to g5 although my bishop on e 2
is hanging I'm glad I saw that glad I
saw that let's get out of the line of
fire of that Bishop and then play here
and push that pond next maybe actually
Knight here why didn't I do that sooner
threatening a killer for 15 seconds 10
seconds for my opponent there less than
ten six five four let's just do this
anything Forks I'm going to do it even
if it's wrong even if it's wrong it's
actually good here though it's good
there though they're out of time back to
Terman 101 I have a lead 101 90 90 87 12
seconds and change 12 seconds and change
here here we go Carroll Khan why did I
go with the Carroll Khan hi
meant to be going with well it wasn't a
mouse slip but I I should be playing
just the Sicilian in reaction to that
um this will visit okay it's my move
right here castle and then okay this is
what's my rug do and that's stupid b5
get b5 in okay that's very weakening
very very weakening and let's get my
Queen to h4 one day h4 coming up
h4 soon or let's back up it's back up no
rush no rush h6 actually there's a rush
these are fast tournaments so fast
there's a lot to rush okay let's do this
there look in the SAC on this square
look into SAC might be pretty good might
be pretty good that sac I'm gonna take
oh yes there we go resignation come on
okay now I'm going to take this okay
we're having a clean trade and then this
and then just block go here I have it
able to win this I'm pretty sure pretty
sure I'll be able to win this but I
wanted to win quicker quicker here check
mate soon okay it's not gonna be soon
but let me just make sure I could do
what not let my time tick it off don't
let my time tick it all oh okay well I
have a time edge the very least I have a
time edge Oh
dropping pieces my clock that clock is
my best friend 121 120 that connect q TI
q TI in there with 68 I need a quick win
give me the quick wins where are they
push that night away hit this night look
for made on f7 here we go here we go set
this up here let me set this up here
okay now that then get my bishop back
here launch it they're gonna do f6
aren't they they're stopping my plan is
the knight close to trapped I think it's
very close to trapped it is trapped okay
resignation come on
resignation it's dead come on you know
you can't win this one you know you
can't win this one right Queen here I'm
on let's come over here that's not a
mouse up I don't want a castle I want to
do something over here okay I'm on this
get my night central I should have given
a check over here this should be six or
something on the roof on the rook at the
end of that so let's come over here
push that pawn I'm on the rook I'm on
the clean my knight is defended oh oh oh
I'm on the Queen my Knights defending
the bishop push again and then remove
the defender push again remove the
defender here we go Queen Nate soon very
very soon move back to tournament what
do we got
144 won for 144 141 140 another guy is
up there oh it's gonna come right down
to the wire let's go here let's get this
I need a much quicker win okay I don't
want this is a much this is a drier
position can I somehow what can I do
what can I do to make this more dynamic
each fund each phone is where it's at
you know you want to turn that edge pun
you can't resist can you let's be sneaky
sneaky I'm not here am I getting that
bishop I'm on the Queen I'm on the Queen
come on resign
you know you want to resign let's take
this I can't let any of my clock tick
come on
okay check their check and then what um
give a check on c5 maybe I check on c5
get this night out of there whether I
also have this check available wow this
is really really beat right here this is
really really beat rip block there's
another fork maybe just close to me real
close to me the king up I need my other
up to do something I think trade a
little bit don't let any of my time tick
no time back determine what do we got
I'm in the lead by a point by a point I
think that guy dropped back he must have
dropped back how much time how much time
is left I couldn't look I didn't even
look I went back I didn't really look I
was joking I really didn't look it
looked like I looked but I didn't look
okay keep my light square Bishop around
come back here and then look for what
let's come over here with f5 and ensuing
f5
f7 now hit move Knight move Knight can I
force the knight to move mmm let's guard
this for just a second ah
let's get that night out of there that
night needs to go okay
no let's come over here where is their
main I want to meet real soon move
Knight move Knight move
um frapp I have to come back okay what
do we have this guy is going so fast I
don't have any time
Wow and I have any time how can I get my
um did I get this 20 seconds um come
here and then is there gonna be a pawn
push okay here I got this oh I could
have taken the rook I want to get to
this square give a check and then get on
h8 and I get to h8 h8 let me get to h8
please let me get to h8 oh man yes yes
yes yes back determine 197 181 Gregory
who's this Gregory has 16 he has 16
games in here we go okay let's get this
in this could get pretty wild still this
could definitely get wild and I was
almost gonna lose my clean right they're
almost gonna lose my clean I should have
recapture with my clean by the way now
am i Knight to f4 f4 here he comes
f4 here he comes okay now I want to get
to e5 very quickly ePHI very quickly I
could get there one of these two squares
jeef g4 or d7 their clock is ticking
what's going on here here we go 'if I've
actually bishop here's threatened mmm
let me go here and then umm I don't know
why did that give a check and then take
my knight take my knight take my knight
take mine ah he take
man why'd I do that okay okay I'm gonna
take on h3 I'm on the bishop at the end
of it I'm the bishop at the end of it no
I gotta go with this okay
30s I have time let's pre move some
stuff don't let my opponents clock or
don't let my clock move at all just let
theirs
why did I do that oh they have them okay
I don't have any time they can't feed
this out can they look here and they
here just do this let's do that give a
check I just play here maybe they won't
take okay back to tournament 201 back to
tournament no I didn't mean
what Oh back to tournament I don't know
what the leaders where we're at with the
leaders I'm by doing in the standings
come on fantasy variation fantasy
variation could lead to a quick kill
maybe we're gonna get a quick kill okay
this is an interesting approach to it
interesting approach here Bishop f4 and
then d6 Bishop f4 and oh the bishops
dead Bishop is dead I'm on the rook I
want to get on f7 f7 f7 f7 real soon my
queen is not really doing a whole lot
there
everything is defended by my opponent
okay
oh okay now maybe there's some problems
let's go here I'm on the knight twice
and a pin Queen trade okay
let me get this out trade what do we add
timewise I'm dropping that pun aren't I
let's go here Knight trade let's defend
get my other one over here there's gonna
be a knight let's do this
Knight here okay
let's come back over here it's double up
what am i doing what am i doing
Forex yes give me that give me that and
then get my King active let's go let's
go here might be a pawn push or
something then rook where lets go King
on push King up rook check back to
tournament they resigned yes to 21 to 20
what to 15 one-minute and change 130 133
130 so in 27 seconds I have what until
28 I can't let my time get down to 28 I
can't let my time get down to 28 I want
to be able to still win this one I can't
let my time get down to 28
okay let's see if I could do this don't
let my time get down to 28 they're gonna
do this come on give me something here
give me something here let's see oh oh
oh
can we have something here something
mate soon yes yes I'm gonna take you
back to turnin to 41 50 seconds
49 48 47 46 45 can I get another one 44
43 42 41 40 40 seconds maybe I could
force this guy into resignation in 40
seconds let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go what do we got
okay checks check right here Oh nuts
then that's not a good move
wait wait wait right here Knight check
and I check on this square close to me I
actually get the Queen get the Queen
right here come on resign resign resign
what do we got what do we got what do we
got
yes the first place confetti that's what
it's all about it's about the first
place confetti
look at that stuff everybody loves the
confetti paper you got the green the
pink the yellows crazy crazy crazy good
games aw that's 241 242 35 to 22:03 Wow